this has been a crazy day you know it's
hard to say this but President Trump
actually surprised me uh-huh
last couple days I thought he was beyond
doing that I didn't think he would like
jump out from behind a bush yeah he
didn't surprise me that way oh no no
president Trump he just he started this
a couple days ago and he kept it up
today he's going after the late Senator
John McCain yeah it's insane
today President Trump claimed he gave
McCain a nice funeral and never got to
thank you that's what he said that's
what he said probably McCain is just one
of many dead people who never thanked
Trump I never heard from Lincoln Gandhi
where is he Amelia Earhart what where's
the note I never got a note from her
she's an ingrate she's an ingrate
day three of President Trump criticizing
the late senator and war hero John
McCain he's on a tear some Republican
senators the Republican senators this is
true are so upset they they gathered
together and decided to almost say
something that's it that's it
that's a lot of guts Wow president
Trump's quote this was his quote I was
never a fan of John McCain and I never
will be
yeah yeah this probably explains why
Trump isn't asked to give a lot of
eulogies I just want to say the guy in
the box I don't get it I never got it
I don't know why you're crying yeah I'm
glad he's gone
I don't want him when I go don't let him
speak
goodbye would you let me make sure
absolutely thank you Andy I don't pre
decease you that's what I'll do
nicest thing you've ever said